vous voulez acheter un iphone c'est un
peu l'idée du jour vous vous dites ok
moi je l'aurais renouveler mon
smartphone je veux soit passé d'android
sur un os soit de changer mon smartphone
d'un os sur un os je veux donc un nouvel
iphone
seulement il ya beaucoup d' iphone
existant en votant sur le site d'apple
il ya un vrai triki a été fait vous avez
les modèles de cette année il ya
quelques modèles un peu anciens le 17 et
le 8 mai sinon globalement si vous allez
regarder ailleurs sur d'autres sites
marchands et bien vous allez trouver
beaucoup d'iphone à différents prix
c'est très compliqué de pouvoir faire
son choix si on ne sait pas réellement
son appartement fait travail pour dire
derrière qu'elle est là il faut le
choisir qu'est ce que ce modèle là tu
m'apportes absolue bien pourquoi je
devrais acheter ce modèle et de quelle
manière je vais l'acheter ne vous
inquiétez pas je vais vous aidez moi
c'est un retour complet de ce qu'on peut
trouver en iphone aujourd'hui sur le
marché je vais vous dire quels sont les
iphone qui valent le coup
calé à peu la différence entre ces
différents modèles justement je vous ai
tous préparés on va se poser derrière on
va regarder je vous met des beaux
papiers aux arrivants c'est très simple
et à la fin de cette vidéo j'espère que
vous aurez éclaircies en attendant pour
l'instant je vous demande bien évidement
de laisser un joli pouces bleus pour
l'algorithme dieu tu pour permettre que
cette vidéo soit vu au maximum de
personnes et bien évidemment vous pouvez
poser toutes vos questions sur vos
iphone en bas en commentaire j'espère
que tout le monde a pu voir un petit peu
s'entraider pour vous aider
effectivement à choisir votre iphone et
quant à moi vous allez voir je vais vous
aider avec des petites fiches c'est
extrêmement simple on se met derrière en
ce moment moi j'utilise ce modèle là
l'iphone 11 promax pourquoi parce qu'il
est vraiment excellent dans tous les
domaines on a le meilleur écran on peut
retrouver aujourd'hui chez apple on a
vraiment quelque chose d'extrêmement
puissant avec la puce à 13 bionique
on est très très bon en photo et surtout
est ce que je voulais vraiment on est
excellent en vidéo et ça pour moi c'est
très très important
sauf que cette petite bête elle peut
rapidement coûter cher on va donc faire
un tour pour voir quel iphone acheté en
2020 le prérequis moi ce que je vous
conseille c'est de ne pas acheter
d'iphone avec un stockage inférieur à 64
gigaoctets
j'ai déjà fait l'expérience est déjà
acheté des iphone à 16 giga à 32 giga et
lorsque vous allez mettre des
applications de la musique ou tout ce
que vous voulez vous allez tout de suite
monté de stockage pas tout de suite
au bout d'un moment vous allez monter le
stockage vous allez devoir supprimer des
applications pour en installer deutsch
les applications une fois vous les avez
installé d'un continue à grossir elle
prend de plus en plus de stockage ont
vraiment pensé partir sur un grand
minimum de 64 giga de stockage c'est
beaucoup trop
un peu plus cher puisque vous allez
pouvoir trouver en 32
française ça peut vraiment voir le coup
le deuxième point c'est la question du
neuf ou douze reconditionnés vous allez
voir ce que vous montrer les différences
de tarifs
en bas il faut savoir sur le neuf vous
avez des garanties 2 en garantie
constructeur un an plus garantie
européenne d'un an supplémentaire dont
aucune garantie de 2 ans vous êtes
tranquille et se reconditionner vous
avez une garantie généralement à
vérifier mais généralement une garantie
de 1 an
bien évidemment si ça vous intéresse
vous habite je voulais marquer en bas
les liens en bas dans la description on
va donc débuter par les iphone les plus
récents les iphone de l'année dernière
tout comme les iphone qui sont toujours
actuelles c'est les iphone de 2019
iphone 11 iphone 11 pro iphone 11 pro
max lens prend max c'est celui là
les grosses différences tout de suite
pour être extrêmement clair tous ses
iphone la tourner avec la puce à 13
bionic qui est la dernière puce de apple
qui marche très très bien dans tous les
cas vous aurez ce cas mieux en termes de
performances maintenant vous allez avoir
une différence en termes d'écrans ici
vous avez un 6,1 pouces c'est un écran
lcd qui est extrêmement bien calibré
mais on est sur du lcd
tandis que là vous avez un écran de 5,8
pouces de 6,5 pouces et dans les deux
cas ce sont des écrans amoled noah
infinie meilleure qualité il vous bien
que l'écran lcd chez apple marche
merveilleusement bien on aura une moins
bonne résolution ici on aura une
résolution de 1792 par huit 128 pixels
c'est pas du full hd c'est un peu moins
mais franchement lorsque vous regardez
lorsque je vais essayer on voit pas
réellement la différence ça fait
vraiment bien le taf je dirais que
l'iphone 11 c'est le bon compromis vous
à des ce qui est vraiment bon en termes
de performance nous avons d'écran qui
fait le taff vous avez une taille
intermédiaire entre les deux 6,1 on est
vraiment bien vous irez moins loin en
termes de photos et en terme de vidéo
que ce que vous allez pouvoir à voir
avec les modèles propres aux epr au max
mais c'est vraiment un excellent
smartphone c'est un très très bon iphone
si vous voulez aller dessus pouvez y
aller sans aucun problème maintenant je
dirais qu'avec les iphone onze pros et
on se prend max
vous allez avoir une meilleure qualité
d'affichage et vous irez plus loin en
termes de photos donc pour les
utilisateurs les plus exigeants
le modèle pro et pro mac pro mac ça va
être vraiment à taille de l'écran qui va
venir changer la tension l'encombrement
est vraiment énorme avec le modèle de
6,5 pouces ça dépasse les poches mais
par contre vous aurez ce qui se fait de
mieux
m faut voir les tarifs sur l'iphone 11
vous êtes à 809 euros
je parle bien évidemment ici d'un modèle
en 64
de stockage sur l'iphone onze pros vous
êtes à 1159 euros toujours sur 1 64 giga
de stockage cliquer sur l'iphone 11
promax vous êtes à 1259 euros c'est tout
de suite beaucoup plus cher sur 64 giry
stockage et si vous voulez encore plus
de stockage tout de suite les prix vont
s'envoler
voilà pour les modèles de 2019
maintenant on va passer au modèle de
2018 monnaie de l'année dernière alors
apple le commercialisent encore sur son
site que ce modèle là l'iphone 10 r on
ne retrouve pas l'iphone 10 aces et
l'iphone 10 s max parce qu'ils ont été
poussés par les nouveaux modèles de
cette année que son iphone
onze pros et on se prend max par contre
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est une
équivalence en fait en termes de gamme
l'iphone qui sert à les remplacer par
les fautes 11
vous êtes sur un écran lcd de 6,1 pouces
exactement les mêmes formats l'iphone 10
aces a été remplacé par l'iphone
onze pros 5,8 pouces amoled tandis que
l'iphone 10 s max a été remplacé par
l'iphone 11 promax 6,5 pouces amoled ce
sont exactement les mêmes configurations
il ya juste le nom qui va changer
c'était plus simple pour apple de se
dire on va rester dans l'iphone
11 11 on se prononce promax une
meilleure lisibilité dans la gamme les
meilleures évolutions c'est plus simple
que se retrouvaient halle du 10 16 17
max et 10 r on comprend pas forcément
quel est le meilleur modèle lorsqu'on
s'y plonge on comprend mais tout de
suite un peu plus complexe on a donc
comme je vous le disais un 6,1 pouces 1
5,8 pouces et un 6,5 pouces on est donc
sur du lcd on est sûr de l'amoled et on
également sur de l'amoled tout comme
l'iphone 11 l'iphone 10r fait vraiment
le taf
l'écran est vachement bien calibré on
n'a toujours pas de full hd mais ça fait
le taf
ici on appareils ce qui se faisait de
mieux en 2018 en termes de photos et de
vidéos par contre là dessus on est sur
la puce à 12
bionic qui fait aussi très bien taf il
ya bien évidemment une différence entre
la puce à 13 bionic et la puce à 12
bionique mais sur un usage un peu
standard et quotidien vous verrez pas
forcément la différence vous prenez pas
la tête là dessus pour moi la différence
elle a vraiment se faire en termes de
portefeuille parce que on a exactement
le même design entre les modèles de 2018
elle est modèle de 2019
on aura plus de performances en 2019
mémo des deux
18 reste quand même très actuelle
toujours pareil sur des versions 64 giga
on se retrouve sur l'iphone 10 r on
commence là à 709 euros
l'iphone 10 s on est à 1159 bêtise de ma
part l'iphone 10 r on est à 8 149 euros
tandis que l'iphone 10 s max on est à
1159 euros c'est pas très lisible ce que
j'ai mis en rouge
en gros entre l'iphone 10 s max et
l'iphone 11 promax qui à 1259 euros on a
100 euros d'écart par contre l'iphone
onze pros et l'iphone 10 s vous avez
quand même un gap qui est énorme là on
est à 1159 euros soit modèles cette
année sur l'autre modèle on est à 8 149
euros donc ce modèle là va être
vachement intéressant de par son tarif
tandis que l'iphone 11 à 809 euros en
passant sur l'iphone 10r à 709 euros
il n'y a pas un gap qui est nord donc si
vous voulez économiser un petit peu vous
pouvez aller sur le modèle de l'année
dernière le 2018
l'iphone dit c'est ce qui par contre est
une belle affaire à ce tarif là je vous
ai mis d'ailleurs bien évidemment tous
les liens dans la description ensuite on
voyage un peu dans le temps et on arrive
sur le nouveau design c'est à dire sur
l'année 2010 est en 2017 apple a fait sa
petite révolution avec l'iphone 10
l'iphone dit c'est le smartphone
événement pour les 10 ans de l'iphone
en même temps ils ont présenté un modèle
qui était le renouvellement de la gamme
un peu standard c'est à dire l'iphone 8
l efo de 8 plus qui succédait au 7 et 7
plus il ya eu un gros gros gros gros
modèle le plus intéressant c'est
effectivement l'iphone 10 qui a eu plus
de succès cette année là alors cet
iphone 10 seront peu plus le trouver en
neuf enfants tout cas moi j'ai pas
réussi à le trouver en neuf
c'est un peu l'équivalent de l'iphone
oms crocs c'est l'équivalent de l'iphone
est 10 sc1 5,8 pouces et un écran amoled
tous ses smartphones tournent sur la
puce à 11
viau nique bien évidemment on sera moins
performant que la nuit monique que la
a13 bionique
néanmoins c'est un smartphone qui reste
je trouve toujours actuel qui commence
très légèrement virée qui va beaucoup
plus de dire en cette fin d'année avec
lé nouveau iphone de 2020 mais que pour
l'instant vous pouvez trouver un tarif
vraiment intéressant en reconditionnés à
499 euros 23 ans 64 gigaoctets de
stockage
donc ça c'est aussi une très bonne
affaire je vous mets le lien en bas dans
la description donc on reste quand même
sur un produit qui est pas mal et qui
tournent tous les deux sur un os 13 qui
est le dernier os c'est à dire vous avez
2019 il reste 13 mai 2018 eyeos 13 et
les données de 2010 est également à goas
treiz dont vous avez les dernières
fonctionnalités on arrive ensuite sur
les designs je dirais un petit peu plus
oldschool
c'est vraiment ce qu'on va venir à
retrouver ici avec les iphone 8 et 8
plus c'est le design d'avant on est sur
les anciens iphone par contre on a là
dessus également la puce à 11 bionique
qui marche qui fait tâche vous aurez
donc exactement les mêmes performances
entre les iphone 8 et l'iphone disent
ses iphone 8 sont pas du tout
complètement désuet par contre attention
aux tags
ici vous avez un écran de 4,7 pouces
vous avez un écran 5,5 pouces est ici
vous êtes sûre du lcd ici il n'ya pas
d'écran amoled
on va pas avoir la meilleure expérience
d'affichage on va pas avoir la meilleure
expérience en termes de design c'est pas
la meilleure expérience globale
ici on n'a pas de faille saïdi ici c'est
très difficile dit vous l'avez à partir
de l'iphone 10 néanmoins si vous voulez
un iphone que vous allez pas payer trop
cher ça c'est pas mal parce que en tarif
vous êtes à 539 euros toujours en 64 go
de stockage sans l'iphone 8 tandis que
sur l'iphone 8 plus vous êtes à 659
euros
bien évidemment toujours vous sentez
adjir du stockage ça ce sont les tarifs
et si vous voulez les tarifs
reconditionnés vous pouvez trouver
l'iphone 8 à 350 euros toujours en 64
giga de stockage et aux alentours 380
euros
ça veut dire que vous avez exactement
les mêmes performances que l'iphone
disent vous avez des smartphones qui
marche en termes de performances qui
sont pas mauvais le design est très
ancien les formations quand même petit
par rapport à ce qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui par contre les prix sont
aussi petit et ça ça peut aussi être un
avantage pour profiter d'une puce qui
reste quand même assez actuelle et après
on arrive dans les anciens modèles les
anciens design les anciens iphone qui
eux par contre ont vraiment pris un coup
de vieux mais contenue encore trouvé et
qui peuvent être intéressants si vous
voulez un iphone et que voulait pas
mettre trop d'argent dessus
eh bien vous avez des alternatives qui
peuvent être intéressantes la plupart
vous les aurez en reconditionnés mais
également en neuf vous êtes dans les
même format que l'iphone 8 et l'iphone 8
plus ici toujours pas de faille s'agit
ici du touch heidi c'est tout du lcd
s'appuie encore fonctionner mais
attention au temps sur l'iphone 7 7 + 6
aces 6 aces plus et l'iphone est ce vous
pouvez avoir un os 13 sur les autres
vous ne pouvez pas avoir eyeos 13 6 6
+55 ses 5 s vous aurez des anciens os
attention pour les mises à jour à te
font soit pas forcément les dernières
applications
ce sont des smartphones qui seront pas
les plus
formant qui peut venir ram est arrivé un
moment où vous n'aurez pas ce qui se
fait de mieux en terme de photos
l'iphone 7,7 plus en photo ça fait à peu
près le taf tout le reste c'est vraiment
pas terrible c'est vraiment pour avoir
un iphone c'est vraiment pour avoir les
applications iphone c'est vraiment pas
avoir l'écosystème apple me dites vous
bien qu'à partir de l'iphone 6 aces 6 5
pds eu les photos cépages et g vous
n'avez pas avoir le meilleur rendu vous
avez pas avoir la meilleure qualité mais
par contre vous aurez un iphone donc ça
ça peut aussi être cool vous allez donc
pouvoir trouver cet iphone 7 à 379 euros
9 à 499 euros pour l'iphone cette plus
en neuf et vous allez pouvoir retrouver
l'iphone c'est ton reconditionnés à 299
euros
c'est à dire que vous avez un iphone qui
est pas mauvais qui n'est pas le dernier
qui parle plus performant avec highway
stress à 299 euros avec une garantie de
1 an donc ça s'appelle quand même pas
mal
si vous allez par contre venir fouiner
ensuite là on est sûr qu'on y fait donc
dans la colonne de droite sur l'iphone 6
aces 239 euros moi je lui l'iphone si
c'est ça peut pas dire qu'il est mauvais
mais il n'a jamais pris un sacré coup de
vieux
le 6 aces plus souvent autour des 299
euros l'iphone 6 vous allez pouvoir le
trouver à 169 euros en reconditionnés
j'ai rien trouvé pour l'iphone 6 plus
l'iphone 5 qui vous et pourrait
retrouver à 72 euros
c'est vraiment pas cher là par contre je
crois qu'on est sur du 16 gigaoctets de
stockage l'iphone 5 aces à 92 euros et
l'iphone 5 c'est pareil à 60,2 euros
sinon c'est vraiment pour dire j'ai un
iphone ça vous permet de toucher pas
très cher c'est vraiment pour avoir
l'éco système ios là dessus vous avez
pas avoir la meilleure expérience tandis
qu'un iphone et ce qu'elle tout petit
format et bien vous pouvez le trouver
pareil à 62 euros en reconditionne
attention parce qu'il se pourrait que en
2020 sorte l'iphone regardez comme
j'écris bien se2 je vous invite bien
évidemment si vous voulez cet iphone the
attendre quelques mois je dirais le
premier semestre 2020 il se pourrait
qu'il arrive mois de mars - avril s'il
arrive pas ce moment la tête attend de
la conférence des développeurs au mois
de juin on verra mais je suis pas sûr
s'il arrive pas à ce moment-là qu'il
arrive après parce qu'au deuxième
semestre 2012 et retrouver les nouveaux
iphone que seront les iphones 11 aces ou
les iphone 12 bon vous voyez dans les
faits ce n'est pas extrêmement compliqué
pour avoir une vision un peu globale et
un peu clair si vous voulez ski c'est
mieux si vous avez les moyens vous
les sur les iphone de 2019 très très
très très bon produit
c'est une fois de plus une question
d'argent si vous voulez vraiment ce qui
se fait de mieux le dernier modèle et
voulait pas mettre trop d'argent vous
allez sur l'iphone 11 809 euros ça
marche s'est pas montré très bonne
affaire sinon on se prononce promax
surtout une question de forme à une
question de taille sur les iphone de
2018 je pense que la vraie bonne affaire
elle se situe au niveau de l'iphone 10s
attention 5,8 pouces c'est pas mal mais
c'est parce que regardent plus grand en
terme d'affichage en termes de
multimédia
je dirais que pour aller sur les iphone
de 2018 ce qui sera vraiment le facteur
décisif avec l'argent si vous arrivez à
le trouver à des tarifs très
intéressants
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut aller parce
que on garde sensiblement les mêmes
caractéristiques qu'on peut retrouver
sur les iphone de 2019 à quelques points
détail près bien évidemment ça dépend
des usages une fois de plus vous amis
tous les liens en bas dans la
description tandis que l'iphone 10 de
2017 commence un peu à vieillir on garde
le même design on a failli samedi on a
un écran qui est cool on a un smartphone
qui est suffisamment performant et si
vous voulez le design des iphones
dernière génération avec faith heidi
plus tarif de 499 euros 53 23 99 euros
23 reconditionnés ça vaut franchement le
coup et c'est une vraie bonne affaire ce
n'est qu'après votre iphone sont pas mal
mais on est dans un autre design c'est
quand on veut rentrer dans l'écosystème
apple quand on veut être dans
l'écosystème d'apple et qu'on veut pas
dépenser beaucoup d'argent pour moi là
le reconditionner est vraiment une très
très bonne option jusque iphone 7 ça
fait encore le taf l'iphone 8 de
préférence et tous les autres modèles ça
va vraiment être pour avoir un produit
eyeos mais ne vous attendez pas à voir
ce qu'elle lui en termes de performances
à voir ce qu'elle me en terme de photos
clairement ça ne fait pas
moi j'ai eu un iphone 6 aces si vous
regardez la qualité des photos de
l'iphone 6 16 de l'époque par rapport à
ce qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui sur
n'importe quel smartphone android
beaucoup moins cher et bien vous allez
voir la différence va est quand même
énorme qui vous voulez un bon photophone
et vous voulez pas mettre forcément
beaucoup d'argent ça peut être
intéressant de switcher vers android
parce que si vous allez trouver un
iphone 6 aces à 2 139 euros 299 euros à
tarif équivalent que sur android avec
des smartphones a plu actuel et bien
vous allez avoir des choses qui seront
beaucoup mieux et meilleure qualité ça
c'est une autre question dites moi ça
vous intéresse qu on en parle que je
fasse un cas un peu une vue d'ensemble
des smartphones sur android pour 2020
par rapport à l'offre actuelle les
iphone du deuxième saut neige 2020 n'ont
pas été présentée puisque je tourne
cette vidéo au même février 2020 mais
voilà une offre complète un panorama
complet pour vous aider un petit peu à
comprendre quel iphone acheté en 2020
j'espère que ça vous aura aidé 6
car je me tape le marc hé bien
évidemment en commentaires vos questions
suggestions interrogations beaucoup
d'amour des pouces et surtout
abonnez-vous comparé à deux têtes de
plus en plus ya plein de choses à dire
des voyages de l'amour de là dessus des
10 et compagnie lorsque vous embrasse ou
fait des gros bisous je donne rendez
vous dès demain pour continuer par
l'etec est un sujet très intéressant
[Musique]
avantageux n'auront pas pas mon gars à
toi
[Musique]
6 à 7 c